si vous projetez de faire un voyage aux
etats-unis sachez que depuis ce matin
vous devez disposer d'un passeport à
lecture optique pour pénétrer sur le
territoire américain sans visa une
mesure décidée après les attentats du 11
septembre pour renforcer la sécurité
dans les aéroports
et ce n'est qu'une première étape amaury
guibert philippe turpault bienvenue aux
états unis à condition de passer tous
les contrôles à l'arrivée dans les
aéroports américains il fallait déjà
faire un relevé d'empreintes puis se
faire prendre en photo et à partir
d'aujourd'hui un seul document est
accepté pour rentrer dans le pays sans
visa
le passeport à lecture optique avec
l'ancien modèle
vous n'avez droit qu'à une seule entrée
aux états unis le passeport à lecture
optique et réputés plus sûrs grâce à ces
deux lignes codé ici en bas du document
c'est après les attentats du 11
septembre que les états unis ont exigé
de certains pays qu'il se dote de ces
passeports nouvelle génération une liste
restreinte 27 pays seulement uniquement
des pays riches dont la france fait
partie des états qui devront aller
encore plus loin dans un an le passeport
biométrique sera obligatoire avec une
photo numérisée et les empreintes
digitales
est ce plus sûres pas forcément la
biométrie c'est la spécialité de ce
laboratoire universitaire ici on teste
par exemple l'identification grâce à
l'iris de l'oeil aux empreintes
digitales et on reconnaît que ces
techniques ne sont pas infaillibles
quand on vérifie par par des empreintes
digitales en fait on fait une
comparaison entre une image de référence
qu'elle était stocké quelque part et
puis une image qu'on acquiert au moment
de la vérification et bien ces deux
images ne sont jamais identiques
complètement reconnaissance faciale de
l'iris ou des empreintes digitales
le risque est donc bien investir des
millions d'euros dans un système qui
n'est pas encore parfaitement qu'un